i want to ask you two uh fun questions
but uh you can
opt out i give you the the uh the escape
of you don't have to answer if you don't
want to
you don't have to use the uh
name if you don't want to either what's
the best investment that you've seen
in
all of crypto whether you did it or
somebody else did it
what what is the one where like
if we go to this is the craziest market
most asymmetric market in the world like
how is some asymmetric can it
get i mean the easy answer there is
bitcoin right it's it's it's not only
uh the most zero to one investment i've
seen in my lifetime
um
but it's also
arguably again not investment advice um
it's arguably one of the best risk
reward investments and continues to be
in in
i think fair to say that there's an
argument to be made that it continues to
be a great risk reward investment um
i think even though i was early there i
think probably the best one i've done
is ethereum
um i've done others with more conviction
and more knowledge since then that have
uh have proven to be good investments
but you know
we we've had a lot of failures too and i
think that's one of the things about
investing in this space that really is
kind of been eye opening for me the wins
are power law wins they're so asymmetric
that you can afford to have a lot of
losses
and because many of the losses are
liquid you often can see that you have a
loss early and you can redeploy the
capital so
in our collection of losses including
total losses that go to zero and things
where we've lost total conviction in
i think we've still made money um
because of the ability to exit early
which is one of the really interesting
characteristics
of having a liquid token economy and not
everything we do is
tokens and um we probably do nearly an
equal amount of equity investments as
well hey you did you like this video
great we make five of them a day and
post them here on this channel make sure
you subscribe like the video and see you
next time